hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the air things masters it's a
round two or rather game two of the
second match game six in total and well
we often say that game six has a very
special way of uh making things
interesting when it comes to uh well
mostly when it comes to a wheelchair
championship match but this is also a
very prestigious match uh so uh game six
is bound to deliver and it uh well i
might have this time as well so let's
check it out magnus has the white pieces
and he opens with e4 we have e5 by on uh
and magnus goes for bishop to c for his
famous bishops opening knight to f6 with
d3 and bishop to c5 and now okay knight
to f3 we have d6 and now knight to c3 we
have knight to c6 so all four knights
have been uh developed and we are now in
the uh
the the well-known uh
uh
areas of the joko piano so knights to a4
going after the bishop on c5 bishop to
b6 and now knight captures on b6 so
magnus wins the bishop uh a captures on
b6 and now a4 uh grabbing more space
here not allowing
black to play b5
and here there are some games that reach
this position but bishop to d7 by nepo
is a new move so already as of move 8 we
have a completely new game
magnus continues developing bishop to d2
we have castles by both players castles
castles and now knight to e7 standard
joker piano stuff shifting knight over
to the king side we want to play c6
maybe d5 or as it happened in this game
not c6 but rather c5 right away but
we're gonna discuss this with b3 by
magnus knight to g6 and now rook to e1
so all very nice developing moves and
now not going for c6 but rather c5 so
instead of uh fighting for the center
with c6 and d5 nipple is fighting for
the center by not allowing magnus to
fight for the center so he has now
complete control over the d4 square and
it's going to be very hard for magnus to
go for that c3d4 idea so here we have h3
by magnus taking away the g4 square from
jan's pieces and bishop to c6 we have b
for now
advancing the pawns on the queen side
and now ian says uh i'm done having this
weak backwards pawn on d6 i will advance
it all the way so there are of course a
couple moves you could play the a4 pawn
it does seem to be hanging but this is
of course why magnus played it he wants
uh jan to capture after rook captures
rook captures the bishop captures he
wants to try and trap the bishop with b5
and now it's uh well it's a very clunky
looking uh
bishop here maybe not uh not
the way to go especially for a rapid
game
if you have all the time in the world to
calculate uh like you do in a classical
game then maybe it's okay so instead
after b4 and nipple strikes in the
center with the d5 we have e cap person
d5 bishop captures on d5 and now magnus
doesn't want to capture of course you
just develop
jan's pieces for free bishop back to b5
so now you don't have to worry about
bishop to c6 going after the a4 pawn
because if black goes after this then
what is your e5 pawn doing that's not um
not the way to go so instead jan plays
e4 very nicely played and d captures an
e4 we have knight captures on e4 and now
b captures on c5 but before recapturing
we have this um uh in between and knight
captures on d2 we have knight captures
on d2 by magnus and now knight to f4 and
now look at this uh all of nepal's
pieces are now going after that g2 pawn
the queen is coming to g5 will join in
the attack can magnus survive this well
there are a couple of ways you could try
and stop this knight the e4 for example
stops the attack on the g2 square also
takes care of the
g5 square but then maybe the queen can
infiltrate this way so magnus decides
it's best to just bring the bishop back
to f1 it will be a very solid defender
here and now b captures on c5 you could
also maybe try and bring the queen into
the game right away but everything gets
sold with knight to f3 so you don't have
to worry as the bishop and f1 is a
beautiful defender so b captures on c5
recapturing material and now knight to
c4 by magnus
we have queen to f6 bringing the queen
into the attack you always have to be
careful if the first rank clears then
that rook could be hanging on a1 so
knights back to e3 attacking the bishop
twice and bishop back to c6 and now we
have knight to g for attacking jan's
queen here queen to g5 now again very
careful you have to be uh the the knight
the queen the bishop everything is
eyeing that the g2 pawn and even if the
knight moves the knight captures an h3
check will be an idea of course the g
pawn is pinned so here g3 attacking the
knight and the bishop covers the h3 pawn
so you don't have to worry about that
and here yan makes a terrible mistake
here you have to go back knight to e6
and then we just trade everything off
for example knight e5 uh we're going to
play rook captures on a4 knight captures
on c6 rogue characters on a1 queen
captures on a1 uh b captures on c6 and
now let's say a nice centralizing queen
to e5 and yes black is up upon but it's
a double c pawn
uh so it shouldn't be all that uh
important
but instead after g3 nipple played rook
8 to d8 and this uh will simply will not
do
it looks like uh there is quite a lot to
worry about we already discussed what a
dangerous position it is but
what about the g captures on f4 uh how
does um how does nipple react to this
well the fact of the matter is that he
can't so magnus just plays g captures on
f4 queen captures on f4 and now queen to
e2 now it's important for the white
queen to constantly keep an eye on the
f3 square
if that black queen reaches that square
then how are you defending against queen
to h1 so here
it would be great if you had this move
but you don't there's certain rooks
rocate the d1 and now if rook captures
an e2 we're just gonna capture on the
eight and black gets checkmated uh
there's no way to uh to stop this so
unfortunately for nipple you can't kick
away uh carlsen's queen from uh d to
square so we have rook d to e8 instead
not allowing this rook a to d1 trick and
now queen back to d3 just guarding the
f3 square we have h5 and ifo now goes
for the attack now you're just uh you
know you're lost you're down a piece but
you have to now give it uh you give it
your all and try to do something here so
knight h2 uh we have rook to e5 hoping
to get that rook to g5 check in but of
course magnus just trades we have
captures captures and now c3 not
allowing the rook to be captured we have
rook to e8 and bishop to g2 now uh the
more pieces magnus trades off the
quicker his victory will uh
will be here as then of course it's just
gonna be an end game where he's a piece
up so queen to g5 pinning the bishop and
the not knight to f3 just attacking the
queen queen to f4 and now rook to e1
even this is in the position uh and uh
you you could try not trading the rook
but then we just trade everything off
with 95 and the bishop captures here
we're gonna play king captures and even
if you deliver one check king f1 there
are no more checks and of course we are
completely winning here so nepo instead
decides to trade and says all right i'm
going to try and win this pawn and then
maybe try and create a past b pawn so
that's also one
uh one idea knight captures on e1 we
have queen captures on a4 and now bishop
captures on c6 so magnus successfully
trades everything off queen captures and
now c for not allowing ayan to push b5
uh g6 and not knight to g2 we have queen
to f6 jan wants to bring the queen to b2
and then try uh some b5 ideas uh magnus
says not a problem uh he plays queen e4
another nice centralizing move uh
attacking the b7 pawn queen to a1 check
with king h2 now queen to b2 guarding
the pawn but magnus just plays king to
g3 and here magnus is already planning
an invasion because this king wants to
come all the way to h6 and then it's
going to be
not so much fun and there's not much
black can do about this if
for example the king is on h6 the pawn
is on f4 there's just no way to harass
that white king it's going to be a very
safe square so here king g7
the thing is you have to play king g7 if
you start with b5 this will
kind of create a pass pawn but not
really because queen e8 to check and you
blunder that pawn so instead after king
g3 king g7 first
and now knight to e3 we have b5 now jan
gets his pass pawn c captures on b5 and
queen captures on b5 but now you've left
this diagonal so magnus of course puts
his queen on this diagonal queen e5
check king to g8 and now knight d5
preparing some very nasty checkmating
ideas queen to d3 check and now magnus
marches forward king to h4 now king g5
king h6 is coming and hopefully uh
checkmate as well so jan will try
everything to stop this he plays queen
to d2 takes away the g5 square from the
white king imagine this preventing your
opponent from bringing your his own king
all the way in your base that's uh
that's something else so here f4 magnus
clears the path for the white king now
queen to g2 not allowing again the king
to cross
but now there's just knight to f6 check
and black is lost regardless of what
black does so nepal plays king to f8 but
this is just the quickest way for magnus
to win and he does it's actually a
forced checkmate in five moves knight
the d7 check king to g8 we have queen to
e8 to check king g7 queen to f8 to check
and he was in this position on move 50
that yanni palmicious resigned to the
game and the game six yet again goes to
magnus carlsen
and uh well as it seems game six always
delivers regardless of of the match uh
so i will see if nipple will be able to
bounce back but it was a really really
intense uh all the five games were so
such incredible fighting chess at some
point someone had to win uh and in this
game it was magnus as the nipple just
gave up a piece for apparently no reason
uh but yeah here we resign because after
king to h7 it's mate on the next move
knight to f6 will be checkmate and of
course that's why he resigned
uh so yeah that's the game game six of
this incredible match or rather game two
of the second day uh magnus takes the
win uh uh i would like to thank cypher
kicks uh leo uh leo joel bourne james
o'toole john cousins and nikita nicholas
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this incredible match uh
until it ends uh thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day